how's it going Brad so glad you could
stop by my name is Breanna back I'm like
all right so friendly where is it oh
sorry Jesus I'll put you down watching
it think it's over here it's got a kinda
swell place ladder but it's blocked by a
huge change I'll add well I'll let that
before I jump down and that's how I
wrong
sorry bidding sorry pity about blocking
net never happy to do it so Keynes all
right so here it was whoa what should I
do
Wow pot do something what nothing bad
idea what are you safe I think John and
I closed it oh no I can't
I think we get
all right you know what I don't trust it
all right so now it's open cuz that's
all I've arrived
[ __ ] [ __ ] I look what your dead made me
run out of I like it that's okay
it's where in the wine cellar 19 but sad
I need me some wine
oh well how convenient give me that what
get away
whoa oh no no more dead bodies am I the
only one left I can see a key in his
penis what is it doing there you're
gonna do something if I pick you up
I knew it not again not here what is
that creature Caliban
oh you're going with moose - I don't
know all right let's hide it
goddamn why don't you pick here nice
legs grab it love it let's just puzzle
these two get up my sash I'll tell
you're doing it
I'll ask me today yes good I'm always
screwed and aren't I where's the key
going to Lord statin that Mouse doing
all right
what am I doing here
I think I saw another opening all right
I need to go in here but I think he's
they up he's there god damn - so
gorgeous whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa Otto
all right screech stroke Marion Oh still
there still there oh good I'm not afraid
of you
go away from me yeah that's right you
better run haha such a [ __ ]
alright potatoes alcohol yeah pretty
close to place I could hang out here
more often
oh let's not go there don't come in here
odda he's coming at co-chairmen
all right weekend let's just sneak
sneaky stagger oh no he sees me not cool
not cool doors
I got damaged closes close them that's
right that's how I roll
hi more blood Allah blood I mean ketchup
at least it has to be open somewhere
else what the hell is that
it'll broke and I need to find a way ahh
how am I supposed to do that this cheese
juice help me so delicious and moist
what are you doing here anyway cheese I
actually think I need to do use my
superpowers that's right my box building
ability there we go put you down there
and that we nice you're a nice box
aren't you there we go that's another
one of you little [ __ ] D boxes alright
feel like I'm playing with Lego here
makes me feel all warm and fuzzy inside
I don't know how else to get up there to
be honest
sure there's a smarter way but we're
doing it the pretty pod way that's right
barrel you're gonna help me and you bet
if we like it actually you don't have to
like it I'm sorry I gotta I'm sorry
alright let go you're gonna put you down
Avila some be on all right Willy
that for coziness all right this is not
gonna go well I got it
come to WA and then a jump
Oh Bao Bao don't [ __ ] with me now that's
right
oh yeah ah whoa what are you doing that
Duke No ah goddamnit
ah you made me fall down you penis
monster ah [ __ ] that's right that's
right that's right
ha ha who's your [ __ ] now you little
man okay you have a big pig whatever wha
it's all your fault isn't it hit him on
the wave oh nice flashes out there we go
whoa what's that see down there oh oh
god damn it what are you doing here I
touch this that's right check out unlock
that door
what is this give me that [ __ ] you [ __ ]
[ __ ] hate you I love you alright 360
[ __ ]
wow that was a bad idea not damaged
can't do anything
Auto all right it's just overheated no
reason to break vodka ah hey what are
you doing here oh damn
where did he go ah nice that must burn
your eyes oh oh
welcome John why don't you just listen
and follow our nose that I wrote you you
will die in this castle
it's the cosplay that kills everyone who
enters it for the last time lay without
his tail cat well you know what you know
what
you know what I think you had one too
many dicks that's right that's right and
shout everyone's he said no genève boss
I could die for those nipples damn it
cut it it's gorgeous
okay but we have to continue can we go
in here it's impossible
well we have a dagger so you know I
think we're done here
that's cold Asko hope he's not still
here
Wow are you here Wow Wow
we can be friends why can't we be
friends why can't we [ __ ] about why
can't we what what the hell is that
Oh Oh God what are you doing here
you know what I have the secret back
waders I don't need that [ __ ] anyway I
like about progress in like a boss
well not really that [ __ ] took
forever but it's okay as long as you're
having fun when you do it and that's the
most important thing in everything you
do except probably when you're going to
kill yourself well why not have fun do a
net just saying or maybe not when you
should well you probably shouldn't kill
yourself anyway I'm sorry I don't know
what you're not going back you're
talking about actually that's kind of
true well you're probably saying what
the hell is he talking about I don't
know if you are right all right let's go
um hey trace I ride you like your mama
what sorry Trey I didn't need your venue
like the sky is quite gorgeous all right
every time pirates well I don't know if
I'm going the right direction
hello I got dammit
yes Yes Doctor puss I remember you are
first things then yes
starter room I got the key for that [ __ ]
that's right hi parent have you mind my
friend Lena punch wha Shama Polina
open the chest pity but it's locked open
the chest booty you can do it be
stronger but it's [ __ ] locked I know
what to do open the shut up hand
god damn it way way way it's shot stuck
lockpick we'll find some cat small tool
why about my penis I get the feeling we
have up oh that's right I have to keep
this a secret from everyone there's some
kind of ritual in the mansion of the
backyard this is her stranger every
night Frank sharp sound I'm all like a
Dalek sorry anymore everyone thinks I'm
just hearing things because I'm home
I had enough I went that open the door
and saw what it was that is I've been
doing back there it's can see absolute I
rest no smeared with blood can't read
any I need to get into that machen well
good thing we have a lockpick betcha
that's right that's okay
all right as you see there I another one
of those keys Oh open you can now open
the chest buddy fine I'm gonna do it
Jesus Christ
Oh crowbar and a book a book
I'm taking you wait is this the new
Harry Potter why did you say I'll read
it later
all right Beck I'm gonna read the [ __ ]
out of you don't do I played a doctor
whoa whoa I'm gonna put you down they're
back
what is this hey you're there and I are
all alone yeah you have a friend talk to
Birkin
I'll be right back all right I know
there was a place hi we need to go back
I think there was a door with a crowbar
you needs up in it and it's over here
all right over here with a weird door
nah ya know I'm right just be correct
though that's totally French yes all
right here we go
Hulk smash Oh hug dragged that's right
oh yeah termination and vanish Asian of
the pen hey you're still here
cool all right what is this I don't know
and now you look like a snake whoa disco
trees holy [ __ ] oh no oh no go first
whoa he likes to swim a lot that's cool
I don't like this I don't know me gusta
oh wow
shouts you're drowning down whoa what is
that
Oh No so now they wanted us Sunday
vacation
[ __ ] me no something's gonna go another
sounds indication where the [ __ ] wow
what the hell whoa what's he doing there
what are you doing hey stop teasing me
[ __ ] disturbing schwa oh no what am i
what am I
oh you teleported me oh hell no ah you
don't tell about me what is this [ __ ]
oh no he's gonna goddamn you forgot your
sad dad stupid [ __ ] you don't even
know how to open doors
stupid [ __ ] maybe I can do something
with that burner Oh Charlie power to max
put the chemical throw a rock against
the heated chemical take color and a
chain reaction alright let's do some
chemistry [ __ ] the first why Wally
shut up Wally goddamn it pathetic what
what is this can I lick you don't wash
my pot all right let's go
don't care don't care don't care don't
care - I care about your [ __ ]
bully kid go through oh you can't go
through I get damn it
I am painting what a nice place to be
paid that's right that's right
shut up and sleep in me come on why
don't you sleep with me what are you
doing there
what are you doing that like a bar like
a bar like about a ridah degree where
was the door I saw it here somewhere oh
no I made a mistake I made a horrible no
way today no no wait am i doing hello
are we cool fishy fishy
I'm your friend I love you oh there it
is god damn you Bashar damn you okay
that's cool alright I'm just gonna take
that and that and that and that and that
and that lad and and I'm a lovely
painting we were reminds me of the onion
very beautiful come fast
god damn it why do i I don't waste a
[ __ ] battle how do we get out of here we
jump like a boss that's right nice you
lost some weight box not before you hang
on the reed is in the next episode so
like and favorite version yo I just
gotta come abroad today I see you next
have no oh what am i doing that's Annie
boy I can play this right I'm noodles
and a graduate joining green